many of us have been binge watching
shows and movies from the comfort and
safety of our couch and all those things
we used to do together theater concerts
comedy clubs they're a distant memory
the idea of being packed into a place
with hundreds of other people is still
largely unthinkable well some countries
are starting to reopen their movie
theaters we still don't have a release
date to return to Canadian cinemas and
traditional theater isn't expected to
raise its curtain to the public until
sometime in 2021 artists musicians and
actors are all struggling and as Robin
Gill explains they're coming up with new
ways to get creative the neon lights on
Broadway are far from bright they're not
even on
[Music]
but chelina Kennedy isn't deterred the
Canadian actor and musician had the
starring role in the musical about
Carole King's life when kovat brought
down the curtain in New York Kennedy was
in rehearsals and fittings for a new
production she made a run for the border
and these days like everyone else
she's hunkered down at home in Ontario
the lights will come back on she insists
but with no idea when I think we will go
back to traditional theater and I think
we must go back to a traditional theater
because there is a name for virtual
theater and it's called film and
television and I think that we can't
replace you know there's a there's
something that happens when there's a
screen between the audience and the
human who's performing the social
distancing festival is hoping to fill
the void for the productions that have
been disrupted or delayed it's a
platform that offers a way for creative
types from around the world to
collaborate whether it's dance art or
music I think it's sort of important for
all artists to figure out ways to
translate their work to digital means
just to have a broader reach Nick green
a Canadian playwright is the brains
behind the festival he sees himself as
an artist matchmaker and wonders if this
could be the future of the Arts there
were a lot of efforts being made to
figure out how to translate the arts to
digital means there were already grant
programs and a lot of industry leaders
trying to look at that question I think
this has expedited that question a huge
amount and live from zoom it's sometime
between March and August life in the
time of kovat is forcing actors to get
creative in the zoom room take Saturday
night not so live the skits and improv
have a flat feel how much you what you
work on
no no I don't believe that will be the
norm people are looking to get back in
the studio and and it's it's a little
bit limiting in terms of what you can do
without any interaction
Jennifer McCarran is the CEO of
Thunderbird entertainment the Canadian
production company behind Blade Runner
2014 I know you're here
she says Hollywood we'll get rolling
soon movies and TV shows have been shot
they're just waiting to be produced both
for the theaters and streaming services
contents a business that does well in
times of recession it's an escape
Netflix
set the standard and now we have Disney
and Apple and Hulu and all of those
aren't startup companies and they're
coming online into streaming because
it's such a hugely successful business
and now people can watch content anytime
on any device anywhere in a hundred and
ninety countries you know 40 different
languages the reach that that has is
tremendous this independent cinema in
Vancouver has been showing films since
1935
the auditorium isn't a full house
anymore moviegoers will have to respect
social distancing rules so seats have
been taken out reduced from 40 rows to
just 20 and the types of movies will be
geared to a certain demographic as we
open up we're in a cater to those people
that are are younger for sure that I
don't have the same degree of fear young
male films are are going to do better
than a young female films males tend to
not have the same degree of fear that
females do in the interim traditional
theatre will take an intermission
[Music]
we may just be pressing a pause button
for a short period the rehearsals are
still taking place even though the Opera
season has been postponed until 2021
during this interlude The Sopranos solos
won't be silenced instead the audience
will experience the virtuosos from their
virtual world there's no question that
the emotions that opera brings out in in
humans will be lost
somewhat online the most important thing
in producing online will be the sound
quality opera obviously is all about the
voice and it's all about music so making
sure that the sound quality of anything
we put out online it says the top level
we can produce out
I'm looking forward to the future when
we can have human connections again
because it will be the cultural sector
that restores everybody back to some
sort of normality some sort of emotional
high that we all get when we go to the
theater and you're right we will not get
all of that in the living rooms of one's
home Toronto's were allowing Xandra
Theatre was closed during the Spanish
flu in 1918 it eventually reopened a
hundred years later it's the same
refrain kovat nineteen will keep
theatres shuttered until 2021 when it's
hoped players and patrons will come back
from being away theatre has gone on for
over 2,500 years there have been plagues
there have been viruses that have been
pandemics and it's always come back I
have to believe that it will come back
again so Korea suspended its run a
Phantom of the Opera in March when a
Canadian cast member tested positive for
Koba 19 three weeks later the cast was
back on stage but theater goers have to
wear masks and they're our sanitization
stops from the door to the auditorium
Canadian theatre is taking its cues from
that part of the world Theater is
essentially a communal experience
otherwise we can all sit at home which
we're doing now and watch things on
screens but that's not the same thing
what happens in a theater and what's
magic about it is the energy between the
audience and the performers and the it
and the energy between audience members
[Music]
Selena Kennedy knows all about that she
thrives on the stage and waits for its
return so I think hopefully this is
gonna make us all much more
compassionate and the kind of stories
that are gonna come out of this time I
think are gonna be very exciting
[Music]